de qué manera esta situación está
impactando a las comunidades locales si
este es un evento que ha ocurrido que en
realidad es de una naturaleza diferente
a lo que sucedió en enero en vitamina el
grande real media de repsol
esto de aquí es el hundimiento de una
plataforma que ha estado inactiva desde
el año 2012 y que es un problema
recurrente en la costa peruana nosotros
en el perú en el norte hace más de 150
años que hay pozos de petróleo y en los
zócalos desde el zinc 150 comienzos de
los 60 hay varias plataformas
es justamente este lugar y un poco más
al norte hacia nuestra frontera con
ecuador es allí es donde hay varias
plataformas que están abandonadas y que
tienen continuas filtraciones de los
pescadores y las comunidades locales son
los principales como en este caso
la principal el factor de conocer que
esta situación estaba pasando debo decir
que el 88% de los granos en 10 años que
se han registrado a un corrido en el mar
y 30% 35% del volumen involucra es decir
son pequeños pero muy frecuentes
derrames que han tenido una repercusión
porque hemos pasado por un desastre
ecológico han habido literalmente
decenas bueno y el hundimiento de la
plataforma no lo que ha generado esta
está preocupación ahora este sería el
más reciente de una serie de derrames
que han ocurrido en el transcurso del
año este mencionaba el dinero por
ejemplo qué medidas deben tomarse para
que esto no siga ocurriendo
si lo que hemos mismos lo que se ha
mostrado en enero y ahora es que nuestro
sistema de control ambiental necesita
urgentemente ser replanteado no lo que
nosotros percibimos es lo que se
menciona en los estudios de impacto
ambiental que dan
el permiso digamos para las
autorizaciones que son
realmente laxas no es así hay
situaciones que no se no se pondrán de
manera adecuada etcétera y en el otro
caso es la fiscalización solamente son
las petroleras las que reportan las
ocurrencias y no hay una verificación
pública boix muy laxa y eso genera que
no tengamos un volumen determinado por
ejemplo en cuanto en la sumatoria de
esos derrames porque no todos están
registrados y algunos incluso no
registran el volumen y así son aceptados
por el sector público necesitamos tener
una nueva vínculo una nueva relación un
compromiso con el entorno marino costero
pero no tan importante en múltiples
actividades económicas y sociales ahora
como se ha manejado las situaciones
anteriores por ejemplo cómo han
respondido las autoridades
muy mal la verdad muy mal hay un gran
reclamo debo decir de los pescadores de
las costas de la costa norte respecto
que lo que ellos mencionan reportan
etcétera generalmente no tienen
consecuencias y eso es una situación
recurrente es recurrente en el sitio
donde haya ocurrido un poco más al norte
que son los lugares más importantes más
antiguos también con este tipo de
actividad en ese sentido nosotros
consideramos que debiéramos tener una
moratoria en relación a
aprobaciones
autorizaciones hasta que hagamos una
revisión profunda de cómo son los
procedimientos para normar y controlar
estas actividades a claras luces es
insuficiente